[Music]
you guys mouths dad into sentence three
is confirmed or is he okay all we know
is there's a new cast member who lines
up with one major fan theory about who
Mel's father is in this video we'll
share everything we know so far
they've just started filming it all
started with a cryptic tweet from Sophia
Carson on May 21st
it just said twas the night before dove
Cameron added a post on her Twitter
account that said night before day one
of descendants three shooting and can't
sleep too excited
that's right May 22nd was a big day for
the cast of descendants three why you
ask because that's the day filming
started for the newest descendants movie
Sophia Carson tweeted that she was
sitting in the hair and makeup trailer
becoming easy again and could it be
happier then she wrote hello gun blew
fans started freaking out alas the fan
verse will have to wait a little while
longer before any new character pictures
are leaked just jared jr. posted a
pretty great picture of booboo Stewart
dove Cameron Cameron Boyce and Sophia
Carson all we know so far is that they
are filming in Vancouver but we have so
many more questions
what will the costumes look like will
Mouse to have those purple bangs will
Maleficent and the other villain parents
make a comeback are you guys as excited
as we are new villains Disney has
ordered some new villains to appear in
descendants 3 this has sparked some new
theories in our obsessed fan brains
about whether or not mouth dad is
confirmed or as Disney trying to throw
fans off track waiting for a big reveal
down the line so the best way to do this
is just to go down the list of new
characters here we go dr. facili a
Disney announced that Jada Murray will
be playing doctor facili A's daughter
Celia they also announced that Jamal
Sims will be playing dr. facili a you
may remember a previous video we made
about a fan theory that Mel's dad could
be doctor facili a here's a quick recap
according to the novel the Isle of the
Lost
evil voodoo master dr. Priscilla a is
headmaster at the school on the Isle
dragon Hall that means he probably knows
Mel's mom Maleficent the question is
doctor
silly a Maleficent get busy he is master
of voodoo magic so it's possible that he
was the one in the enchanted forest
calling mouths name in the d3 teaser so
if dr. facili a is Mel's dad and it's
now confirmed that he has another
daughter Celia
that means mal also has a sister she
never knew about that could be
interesting sneeze twin sons
apparently Smee has a set of twin sons
named squeaky and squirmy who will be
played by Christian Convery and Luc
Rossler you all know who Smee is right
he's Captain Hook's loyal sidekick in
Peter Pan though there is no mention of
the role of Smee being cast in The
Descendants 3 film that leaves us with a
big fat question mark what happened to
Smee where is he these adorable kids
playing his twin sons are still pretty
young which means either Smee departed
way too soon or he's still out there
somewhere in which case the fan theory
that he could be Mouse dad could still
be a possibility mal would be the big
sister to the cutest twins ever Krunk
is still in the running we found a
behind-the-scenes video of the cast
during descendants 3 rehearsals there
seems to be a common thread in the silly
videos that were strung together they
were referring to Krunk and Ozma and
more than once the first time Dillon
play fair who plays Gill the son of
Gaston is doing a weird voice it sounds
as if he's doing an impression of Krunk
and he definitely says the name yzma
then it sounds like dove Cameron is
doing an impression of yzma when she
says wrong lever we've said it before
and we'll say it again Krunk would
definitely make for some fun moments and
hilarious comic relief but if Krunk is
in d3 who will play him and who would
play yzma that would make for some
entertaining moments we wouldn't want to
miss Hades alright now for the real
reason we're here
Disney literally just announced that
they have cast American horror stories
Cheyenne Jackson in the role of Hades
into Senate's three fans are sure that
this confirms Hades is Mel's father it
makes sense evil blue hair like the blue
flame in the teaser a lot of signs point
to Hades but no one has announced that
just yet most fans think mouths dad is
going to be Hades but why would Disney
give that secret away so early dove
Cameron even posted a pic of her in
Cheyenne
cinsay they have their Hades god of the
underworld in a poorly lit sushi dinner
selfie she says she loves Cheyenne
Jackson and that he is her dream Hades
she ends by saying she can't wait for us
to see what's coming again something's
fishy
do we all honestly think that Disney
would give away such a big secret over a
year before the film will be released
almost as if they're trying to throw
descendants fans off the trail with this
one
we all think mouths dad is going to be
Hades and then they drop the bombshell
that he's actually someone else fans
will be blown away and Disney will get
to keep the element of surprise
fan theories there have been a lot of
fan theories that could still be in the
running
many people think mordioux is a big
contender for the part of Maus dad
mordioux was originally a human prince
and Maleficent did say in the book that
she had a moment of weakness with a
feeble human so that checks out fans
also pointed out that the blue lights in
the d3 teaser could be the will of the
wisps that led Merida to her destiny in
the movie brave some fans did think they
heard a Scottish accent when Mel's dad
whispered her name
then there's the theory about King
Stefan being Mel's dad as we mentioned
before King Stefan checks off a lot of
qualifying boxes to be Mal's dad seems
like the obvious choice given the
history of Maleficent and Stefan so what
do you guys think does the announcement
of Cheyenne Jackson as Hades confirm
that he's Mel's dad or is Disney trying
to trick us let us know in the comments
if you're like us you're dying to find
out what dissonance theory has in store
for our favorite villain mouth well once
2019 comes around you'll finally be able
to get some answers
for now let's theorize on the
possibilities surrounding mouths
identity first time at the things don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's dive right into some of the most
convincing dissonance 3 theories on the
markets with the dissonance 3 release
date being set for the summer of 2019
fans have a long way to go and how they
get the full story but you know we're
here to help out with a few theories of
our own if there's one thing we just
can't shake it's the possibility of mal
being a mermaid but whether she
previously knew about her purple tail or
not is up for debate let's go through
some of the possible scenarios that
could timeout to the darkest depths of
the ocean his mouths dad really a human
a
without saying that many of us have been
dying to know who mouths real father is
this information will soon come to light
and anyone who has watched the short
teaser can hardly wait for the cat to
get out of the bag the teaser showcased
a purple haired mal walking through an
enchanted forest and stumbling across a
floating blue orb mal soon realizes that
the orb is calling out her name and as
she gets closer and closer
she shockingly blurts out the word dad
this came as a shock to many of us
especially since it's been said that mal
father is a human so how could a human
be able to create a floating blue orb in
the middle of nowhere
some people believe this orb to be a
trap and others think that the truth
behind Mouse heritage has gotten
scrambled along the way descendants to
the Isle of the Lost confirmed that mal
father was indeed human but could it be
that now was tricked into this to take
her mind off the bigger picture
since mal father is often referred to as
someone who shouldn't be named it's hard
to believe that he could be something as
trivial as a human being after all why
would the great Maleficent to be
attracted to a powerless human the
theory that mouths dad doesn't have a
magical bone in his body is hard to
digest which is why fans have concocted
the theory that he's actually King
Stefan from Sleeping Beauty should this
be the case this would make mal and
Aurora half sisters did now make a deal
with King Triton so perhaps one of the
biggest curveballs in descendents three
is mouths shocking mermaid tail since
she's never hinted towards being related
to mermaids we're left to consider the
fact that her mermaid tail is borrowed
King Triton is a powerful Merman who has
the ability to alter the physical state
of countless life forms we clearly saw
this demonstrated in the Little Mermaid
when he used his Trident to turn his
daughter Ariel stell into human legs
since King Triton and now have a common
enemy fans believe that he might have
used his Trident to turn her into a
temporary mermaid this would make it
easy for her to navigate the sea while
trying to locate uma it's no secret that
King Triton and Ursula have bumped heads
in the past so why would things be any
different between them and her daughter
for now it seems as
though the real matches between now and
Emma so it could be possible that King
Triton has granted now mermaid powers
seeing mouths mermaids hell in the
teaser was definitely unexpected and it
left tons of room for fans to speculate
do you think that mal and King Triton
are working together or could their
relationship be something else
altogether watch until the end to find
out could now be a mermaid it's hard to
believe that mal is a mermaid especially
since her mother is the big and bad
Maleficent this isn't what was showcased
in this short under the sea teaser
though which has left many of us utterly
confused if there's one thing that
struck us as strange it's how mal
confidently leaped into the ocean as
though she'd done so many times before
in the end the ocean is umas plain
ground so why escape her grasp by diving
into her waters while mal has powers of
her own we never once believed them to
be strong enough to transform herself
into a different species altogether with
this in mind some fans are inclined to
believe that mal is indeed a mermaid
this shines a light on Maus heritage
once more making us wonder of her father
could be a merman of some sorts this
would directly contradict the belief
that Mal's dad is a human but maybe just
maybe this information was fed to
viewers in order to distract them from
the truth did mal father use the
mysterious blue orb to come clean about
her hidden heritage if so this could
explain why she didn't think twice
before diving into the deep dark and
dangerous
ocean his mouth-- father King Triton
with the way things ended in the
descendants under the seed teaser mini
fans are confident that Mouse father is
none other than King Triton himself
while it is true that the underwater
King is known for having fathered
countless daughters he hasn't
necessarily done this outside of wedlock
then again Maleficent has the ability to
manipulate her shape and form so could
it be that she tricked him into
fathering her child this is all
speculation of course but we can't deny
that it makes a great deal of sense
since mal father has been a mystery from
the start her real dad could literally
be anyone when you take a deeper look he
might start to realize that King Triton
and now have a lot in common
for starters there
enemies both happen to be sea witches
and to make matters more convincing now
is going head-to-head with the daughter
of King Triton's biggest rival could it
be that history is repeating itself or
are we swimming a little too deep
if Mal's father is indeed King Triton
this will cause more questions than it
does answers but in the end descendants
three takes place underwater for some
reasons could another villain be mounts
dad if there's one thing we aren't
lacking its theories about who mouthed
father is a fan named Emily took to
Twitter to put her theory into motion
she thinks that mouths dad is none other
than the wicked Fantasia villian
Chernabog she believes this to be true
because Chernabog and Maleficent were
seen hanging out on numerous occasions
after the villains took over the house
in her opinion it looks as though these
two were somewhat dating while Chernabog
could very well be Mouse dad this would
make her a demigod of darkness
after all Chernabog is as evil as they
come so why would Maleficent
continuously insult Mouse human heritage
could it be that she wishes to shield
her daughter from the truth or is it
possible that she doesn't want her
daughter unlocking her true potential
and overpowering her dear ol mom as some
of you might know Chernabog is the most
powerful disney villain of all time he's
also the most feared and unpredictable
character in his category while some
people might see a resemblance between
his and mouthes characters we can't help
but think that she deserves a little
better after all her heart is far from
being filled with darkness half mermaid
or demigod perhaps one of the most
popular descendants three theories is
the one that places Hades as mal stat
Hades is the main villain in Disney's
1997 musical Hercules despite having a
fun and wicked personality Hades is evil
beyond belief but then again we would
expect nothing less from the god of the
underworld
thirsty actor Cheyenne Jackson is the
man behind Hades genius and were excited
to see what he has in store for
descendants three since he is one of the
newest cast members fans are convinced
that he's mouths long-lost dad there are
many clues to this theory one of them
being that the mysterious orb mouth
found in the enchanted forest was made
out of a bright blue energy since this
color is often attributed to Hades
himself this theory could potentially
make sense if there's one thing that
keeps confusing us though it's the fact
that mal is said to be half-human it
would be unlike the descendants
franchise to make us believe that Hades
is Mal's father only to pull the rug
from under our feet at the end of the
movie so for now many fans are skeptical
about the relation between these two
villains half-sisters with Ariel
countless fans can believe their eyes
when they saw a gorgeous purple tell
attach two mouths lower half this is
because it isn't every day that your
favorite dissonance character spouts
fins where her feet used to be for some
reason the fact that now transforms into
a mermaid has nothing to do with magic
and everything to do with genetics
despite being born with legs
mouths heritage might have kicked in the
second she dived into the ocean but then
again this is all just speculation while
characters King Triton and Ariel don't
seem to appear on the descendants three
cast member lists fans still believe
that these characters could have a
correlation if Maleficent did indeed
mate with King Triton this would make
mal and Ariel half sisters which could
explain why mal has some soft qualities
and only a hero would pride themselves
on since descendants fans have been
dying to see Ariel and melody pop up on
screen this family reunion could quickly
turn into a tearjerker since the third
installment of the descendants franchise
has hints of The Little Mermaid
we can only hope for its main characters
to make an appearance
but since descendants mainly focuses on
the children of our favorite villains
and heroes this would place princess
melody at the front line so if King
Triton is in fact mouths dad this would
make now Melody's long-lost aunt for now
there's no way of knowing as The Little
Mermaid crew will find themselves in
descendants three but hey there's
nothing wrong with hopeful wishing
does this fast make me look fat mermaids
bears and human princes with so many
possibilities surrounding nows heritage
it's only normal for countless theories
to pop up regarding it safe to say that
some make more sense than others
considering what the end of the sea
teaser brought forth many of us are
inclined to believe that malice father
is a merman according to a fan named nat
this is far from the truth nat took to
twitter to discuss who she believes to
be mouths dad and we have to admit that
the girls got some stone-cold facts on
her side NAT says that mordioux who is
the villain and brave is mouths real dad
and here's why
for starters mordioux was once a human
prince which could explain mouse human
genetics secondly more do eventually
transforms into an evil bear which would
make him a villain this could place him
and Maleficent in the right place at the
right time but the most convincing
arguments of all comes in the form of a
tiny blue orb anyone who has watched
brave knows that Princess Merida was
lured into the forest by a magical blue
light which is exactly what was
showcased in the under-the-sea sneak
peak by now we all know that Maleficent
sees Mouse father as weak and if he is
in fact more do this would explain a lot
after all mordioux sacrifice himself in
order to free his spirit there are some
fans who swear that mouths dad sounded
Scottish in the teaser which would
directly tie him to the brave franchise
for now though there's no way of knowing
what is true and what is lost so there
you have it some of the most popular
descendants theories surrounding the
franchise's third installment for now it
looks as though mal being a true born
mermaid is definitely a possibility but
hey only time will tell which theory do
you believe to be true let us know in
the comments and find out which viewers
agree with you at the end of descendants
two we were told by Emma that the story
hadn't quite ended yet so we were all
thrilled but not shocked to learn that
descendants three will be coming out in
2019 there have been tons of teasers
that have left fans wondering if mal
will end up being crowned Queen let's
start out with a quick recap descendants
set out to answer one of the greatest
questions of our time what happened to
our favourite Disney stars after the
credits stopped rolling
we learned that Belle and beasts of
married and now rule over a kingdom
known as the United States of auradon
they have a son named Ben who is
naturally next in line to inherit the
throne over the course of the first film
we see Ben falling in love with Mal the
daughter of the great sorceress
Maleficent despite all of the subterfuge
and spell casting these two managed to
fall for one another and begin a
relationship and even though Maleficent
ends up crashing his coronation he still
ends up with a crown making him king of
auradon in the second movie we see mal
is struggling to live up to what a
king's girlfriend should be like things
eventually get so tense between Ben and
mouth that mal retreats back to her
former home on the Isle of the Lost
the Isle is now ruled by Ursula's
daughter uma who ends up kidnapping Ben
and holding him hostage
naturally this does not go over well
with mal and friends who hatched a plot
to rescue their king at one point
looma shows off how much she takes after
her mother by bewitching Ben to fall in
love with her
however mal managed to win him back and
the day is safe now that these two crazy
lovebirds found their way back to each
other
could they have decided to finally tie
the knot in descendants three let's keep
in mind that even though this is a
live-action series this is still Disney
we're talking about breakups are pretty
much unheard of between characters in
fact it seems like the very moment a
Disney character locks lips with someone
they're forever bound to one another
then they're destined to get married
have kids and produce a few directed DVD
movies that truly is the tale as old as
time as far as Disney is concerned with
that in mind even though the descendants
franchise is a reimagining it does
follow pretty classic Disney rules
namely that true love conquers all and
when in doubt just plant a kiss on
someone to save the day in most Disney
movies being a king or queen is seen as
the ultimate goal but ruling a kingdom
is a ton of work it's no surprise that
mal would have trouble adjusting to this
major lifestyle change but again we're
dealing with a place where love really
can conquer all I love you then I've
always loved you has she and Ben decided
to tie the knot making now the queen
consort of our town we already know that
actor Mitchell hope will be
reprising his role as King Ben and we've
seen him wearing his golden crown fans
who follow actors stuff Cameron on
Instagram may have also noticed what
some believed to be a big clue recently
she posted a photo of herself with some
dedicated fans and it looks as though
she's wearing her male costume and on
her head we couldn't help but notice
that there seems to be a crown sitting
there Cameron wrote in the caption that
the girls in the photos promise to keep
aspects of descendants 3 a secret which
means that there could be spoilers in
this photo on one hand it would be
pretty believable if this meant that mal
was gonna be crowned Queen after all
people frequently dawn crowns to show
that they're taking on a position of
power but there is a precedent of
Descendants characters wearing crowns
just because take evey for instance who
we frequently see with some sort of
decorative head where Evie is the
daughter of the Evil Queen but that
doesn't necessarily make her a princess
it's revealed at one point that despite
her title the Evil Queen has no royal
status meaning that Evie doesn't either
if Evie can choose to accessorize with
the tiara why can't her good friend mal
do the same now let's not forget that
even though mal is new to the royal life
she isn't a fool she knows that as the
girlfriend of the king wearing a crown
would send a clear message that she
expects to be treated like a royal as
well
and considering Mel's personality and
her reluctance to adapt to royal life
this doesn't seem like something she
would do unless of course she and Ben
have tied the knot and she's officially
Queen there's no denying that Ben and
mal are each other's one true loves and
they've overcome significant
relationship obstacles during their time
together during descendants two we saw
them planning a cotillion which would
make mal an official Lady of the court
going through the cotillion would mean
that mal and Ben are engaged to be
engaged
although circumstances delayed the event
we saw mal wearing Ben's signet ring so
it wouldn't be surprising to see the
cotillion take place or learn that it
happened off screen we also saw mal
transform into a dragon for the first
time in fans had mixed reactions to this
some believe this proves that mouths
evil side isn't as gone as she would
like it to be but director Kenny Ortega
disagrees he believes that the dragon
simply represents a powerful side of mal
and now it emerged when it came time to
protect someone she loves if turning
into a dragon for someone doesn't
signify a serious relationship we have
no idea what does Disney also released a
teaser on Instagram that shows mal
standing in front of a castle
could this be their way of confirming
that mal is going to be Queen in the
third movie we have also heard rumors
that will finally learn the identity of
mal father into Senate's 3 well we can't
wait to learn who it is it would make
sense that he shows up just in time to
walk his daughter down the aisle at her
wedding
considering all of the evidence the
storylines and Disney's history it would
honestly be pretty shocking if mal
didn't end up as Queen if she wants to
be with Ben and it's clear by now that
she does she's gonna have to end up
accepting the crown at some point plus
in the third movie we're getting
introduced to tons of new characters
meaning that mal and Ben's romance will
likely be taking a backseat to other
plot lines what do you think will happen
in descendants three drop your theories
in the comments section Disney's
descendants three is coming in 2019 and
they dropped a huge photo that has
everyone talking let's take a look at
the theory that mal and uma are becoming
besties we can't wait for the release of
descendants three and we know you can't
either subscribe today to keep up with
all the news surrounding the new movie
the bombshell on July 20th 2018 Disney
released an awesome d3 deets video with
a bunch of awesome photos from the set
of descendants three these deep three
deets videos give us life we love steam
shots with director Kenny Ortega dove
Cameron Sophia Carson and the rest of
the cast we got some amazing shots of
the core for being friendship golds we
even got a look at the dog who plays
dude but one photo in particular left a
shoo-in one photo Malin uma look
particularly buddy-buddy
they are fist bumping and grinning at
each other say hey why did your jaw drop
like ours did they are basically mortal
enemies in the last movie and now we see
this crazy AF Peck from the set we have
so many questions
series
Disney just drops a bombshell like this
with no explanation they must know we
are absolutely crazy trying to figure
this out and they succeeded in getting
everyone talking about it as you can
imagine this photo led to a lot of fan
theories on the Twitterverse fans of vks
are totally shook over this photo and so
are we
we've dissected what this photo may mean
for the relationship of mal and Huma in
descendents 3 and the backstory
let's throw back to descendants 2 for a
quick refresher if you haven't seen the
second movie spoiler alert
basically mown is feeling like she
doesn't belong in auradon she gets all
this attention from the press because
she's dating King Ben she even dyed her
hair blonde to fit in
don't worry dizzy totally fixed that for
her al Jamal gets caught doing magic by
King Ben they get in the huge fight and
mal goes back to the Isle
leaving behind Ben and her three best
friends this is where we meet the fierce
and unforgotten umma daughter of Little
Mermaid's Ursula she is a lifelong rival
of mouths because mal rejected her from
joining her gang of villain kids
um brood of course mal hadn't quite
discovered her good side yet but their
hatred for each other goes way back but
miles away in auradon Ouma gets her
chance to take over Mao's old territory
she's a pirate with her two cronies
parry hook and Gil Gaston she kidnaps
Ben and there's an awesome sword
fighting showdown between our core four
and the Pirates but now still feels like
she doesn't belong on auradon somehow
Ouma then sneaks a love potion to Ben
after Mao loses her spell book on the
Isle we still have no idea how she
managed that but uma says she dove into
the water while the magical barrier was
open and swam to our dime pretty easy
for the daughter of a sea witch mal is
totes heartbroken but then she sees the
stained glass picture that Ben designs
she realizes been totally loved the real
her all along now breaks the spell by
kissing Ben because true love's kiss
works every time they are seriously
relationshipgoals
uma and now have an epic
showdown pluma turns into a giant
octopus and math suddenly becomes a
dragon then jumps into the water to stop
their fight and octopus puma swims off
toward the isle after a huge musical
number umma looks at the camera and
teases us telling us that wasn't the end
of the story we remember exactly how we
felt when we knew there was a
possibility of a third movie now we are
trying to figure out exactly what the
rest of the story is the photo okay
let's talk about this huge bombshell
that Disney dropped on us we are going
to totally overanalyze this thing
because we are so shocked Mao and Ulla
are walking side by side through a
garden or forest they are looking right
at each other and they don't appear to
hate each other in fact they are smiling
and throwing each other a fist bump they
don't even look like frenemies they just
look like friends Eevee is behind them
looking on and we can't cried and make
out her expression is it jealousy or is
she happy too
we just don't know behind Eevee is Harry
hook who is looking behind them maybe
he's being a lookout is this the same
forest where mouths used the blue light
from the teaser why are they together so
many questions
this photo is amazing but it leaves us
with way more questions than answers we
love that we get to see an awesome view
of their new looks does a new look mean
a new friendship the d3 dates video has
another photo with mal and uma this time
with the smiling Harry and Gil uma
appears to be talking about something
and now look shocked but they still
don't look like they hate each other are
these photos from behind the scenes or
are they still shots from the actual
movie
we have no idea and it's driving us
crazy so we have known for a while that
Huma is returning in the new movie but
this is really our only hint as to what
her new role will be we know that there
are a ton more villains so we don't know
how much power
uma has left on the Isle we also know
mal will be meeting her dad do you think
uma plays a role in that reconnection
whatever her role is we know Emma will
be just as fierce as she was in
descendants to the tweets Twitter was on
fire after this photo dropped some fans
had questions and not
had theories no one could stop talking
about this pic Twitter user adds
blossoms Choni tweeted China and MacLean
the actress who plays boom ah she asked
what Malan umas relationship was going
to be in the new movie
China replied with just one word
complicated could that be any more vague
who we guess that makes sense though
Malan Ouma have hated each other their
whole lives we can't expect them to
instantly become friends we're sure
there will be a frenemies stage at the
very least but couldn't China give us a
little more to work with another Twitter
user at alley Beulah's ah ot5 asked if
Eevee is jealous of Mao and Ummah we
didn't get an answer for this what do
you think
do you see jealousy on Eevee space Eevee
space is kind and unreadable is she
giving you my evil eyes is that little
smile genuine or fake we'd like to think
Eevee would be happy if Malin Ummah made
friends but she certainly would not
Uma encroaching on her BFF territory
don't mess with v's people she's best
Eagles at least one person thinks Eevee
looks really angry add Swan John he's so
nice
tweeted a photo of an angry penguin
implying that's exactly how Eevee look
how hilarious is that Eevee would be so
offended to be compared to a penguin
don't you think she is too pretty for
that and @j but 2019 tweeted the actress
with a detailed plot question so does
this mean mal is going to need Emma's
help and they make up and uma joins our
dawn Geoff Cameron just tweeted back
hahahahaha sounds like that might be a
no but she still didn't confirm if Malin
uma become friends or maybe she's
laughing because this fan figured it out
@j but 2019 went on to say she is so
excited for descendants three and that
she can't wait it has so many questions
but no answers girl same Twitter user at
Erin Mahajan one two three is sure that
Malin uma are legit friends in the new
movie
and Nadia Yara 13 seems to agree and at
Beyonce Laurel is just as shook as we
are at this possibility the emotions
about this photo
running high on twitter series there are
so many possibilities and they are all
pretty crazy one scenario involves now
needy numa's help we know now meets her
dad who we assume is Hades it's totally
possible that mal needs Zuma's health to
get to the underworld to meet him after
all he is king of the underworld we also
know there is another villain and his
daughter making an appearance dr. Vasily
R from The Princess and the Frog and his
daughter Celia and there is photographic
evidence that Audrey's return will be
way more wicked it sounds like the Isle
of the Lost might be getting a little
crowded with so many more villains it's
possible
uma doesn't have the influence she once
did will Celia be her new VK rival is
dr. castle we are going to do to himself
into power I know the theory is that you
might comes to mal for help
mal is super powerful obviously since
she can return into a Sabbats dragon
she's definitely a force to be reckoned
with and she is way stronger than Harry
and Gil who are sometimes a little too
goofy it's totally possible that uma has
to bite her pride to ask for nog help to
get rid of some of those new villains
that would be super cool do you think
now would offer to help
uma pretty easily or will she take some
convincing some of the fans seem to
think of partnership with uma and now
would make evey super jealous at Allie
Bulaga ot5 warns uma to watch out for
Eevee because she is crazy protective of
her bestie we all need an Eevee in our
lives don't you think we have a feeling
uma really would not like Audrey and we
know mal doesn't really care for her
either we could totally see the two of
them teaming up to take down a
villainous Audrey that showdown would be
wack of course it's totally possible
that this photo that has everyone on
fire is just a behind the scenes shot
we know dub Cameron in China and MacLean
our friends in real life maybe the photo
is snapped after the camera stopped
rolling
Disney probably knew exactly what they
were doing when they shared this photo
now everyone can't stop talking about
descendants 3 we know uma must have some
good in her if King Vince saw it it must
be there maybe her chance at Ridge
and lies within a friendship with Mal it
seems like a perfect fairytale story to
us don't you think some people have
speculated that now might still have a
streak of evil in her is it possible
that Mao has to go back to her wicked
ways in the new movie for some reason
after all she did turn into a Maleficent
style dragon at the end of the sentence
- director Kenny Ortega said that the
transformation was more about being
protective of fen and her friends than
being wicked but we do know that now
would you absolutely anything to protect
her loved ones she's fierce
AAF there's a good chance she'll have to
tap into her bad roots to save Oregon
one last time more fan theories Disney
Channel has done a great job of keeping
the story line of descendants 3 under
wraps
too great of a job if you ask us we are
searching for every Tivat we can finds
and we're feeling distant in desperation
there are several other fan theories out
there about the plot of the new movie
and they don't all have to do with uma
and now we know Mouse somehow meets her
dad in this new movie we don't know
whether she'll meet him at the beginning
or at the end and while most people are
pretty sure her dad is Hades a few
people disagree in the 2014 live-action
film Maleficent the sorceress has been
involved with King Stephen if you know
what we mean but we aren't sure Disney
Channel would include an infidelity
storyline and if that were true then mal
would be Audrey's and that might be
enough to turn Audrey evil but this
seems a little too pg-13 for a Disney
Channel original movie another theory is
that Mouse dad is the king who is turned
into the bear more due from brave the
fans who believe this think that the
blue lights in the forest are the same
will-o'-the-wisps that take Merida to
her destiny in the 2012 film we don't
know how likely this is but it would be
awesome to see an underrated movie like
brave getting some villain love in
descendants 3 and we would love to see a
fiery Merida in auradon one last theory
about mouths dad is that he is the
Horned King from the Black Cauldron this
is based on the blue flame that we see
in The Descendants 3 teaser trailer
there are
of theories surrounding Audrey's wicked
new look we know she has Maleficent
scepter did she pick it up at the end of
the first movie when Maleficent was
defeated one theory is that she really
has gone wicked and is out for revenge
the other is that she is under some
magical spell that is causing her to act
this way either way evil Audrey is going
to make this movie awesome AF which
theories do you think are true do you
think Malin uma are going to be friends
or was that just a behind the scenes
shot don't be shy let us know in the
comments descendants - left us with so
much unfinished business and new stories
to be told that we can't wait to see
what is coming next in the following
movie no one even confirmed that we were
ever going to see descendants 3 but it
doesn't hurt to talk about all the
things that fans want to see stay tuned
until the end to know more about mal and
Harry's secret story umas unfinished
business we all remember the end of the
second movie just when we thought that
everyone was going to live happily ever
after luma surprised us by saying you
didn't think this was the end of the
story did you this is the same thing
that mal said at the end of the first
descendants movie and we all got the
chance to see the second film shortly
after does that confirm that we are soon
going to see descendants 3 unfortunately
nothing is guaranteed that's because
this line wasn't even in the script so
it was not even supposed to be there no
one knows if there is going to be a
third movie yet as the director Kenny
Ortega said that they are still waiting
to see how the fans will react no matter
what we know that there is still some
unfinished business with uma and we want
to see what is coming next
the actress China and McClain wants to
stay a villain so we can totally imagine
uma trying to make an unfair agreement
with mal just like her mother did in the
Little Mermaid after all she was not
interested in coming to the good side
when Ben gave her the opportunity but
she can always change her mind as
Cameron boys who plays Carlos thinks
that she could come to their side and
they would all fight their parents
together no matter what we absolutely
need a third movie to see who was right
hey guys we are so excited to announce
here
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section she left me
here from you see you there
Carlos and Jane it took a whole movie
for Carlos to finally ask Jane to go to
the cotillion dance with him he was so
shy that mal tried to give him a candy
that would make him tell the truth but
dude the dog ate it and started speaking
in English it was the best thing that
could happen to him at the end as man's
best friend convinced him to talk to the
girl that he loves saying than if she
doesn't love him back it means that she
is not the one and we are really happy
to see them together at the dance even
though the fairy godmother didn't even
understand that they were together no
matter what they were ready to live
happily ever after but with these two we
know that it's going to be really
interesting this is why we want to see
how they are going to be dealing with
their new relationship in the next
descendants movie now all we need is for
Jay to find a soulmate - he went to the
cotillion dance with Loni but they were
probably just friends at the time this
is why we want to see what will happen
between these two or even if Jay will
ever find another special someone
auradon is the best place to live a
fairy tale story and we hope that every
villains kid will have the chance to
know what love is
Dizzy's opportunity as soon as we saw
dizzy lady Jermaine's granddaughter
working as a hairstylist on the Isle of
the lost we all wondered what she was
doing there the young girl was too nice
to be a villain stuck on this island
actually she was only the victim of her
family who treated her like a servant
but we think that they were just jealous
because Disney has everything it takes
to be a princess she wanted to go to
Oregon so badly that she gave all the
accessories that she made to Evie she
thought that if her friend wore them she
would feel like she is part of Aragon -
does he thought that she couldn't be
happier when Evie said her name on the
red carpet but something even better was
coming next she received an invitation
reading that she would have the chance
to attend our Adhan Prep Evie didn't
only ask Ben to let dizzy join them but
she also wanted to give this chance to
many other kids who lived on the Isle of
the Lost
do you know what it means we could see a
lot of new characters in descendants 3
director Kenny Ortega even
said that every once in a while he
thinks about new characters we hope that
we will also get the chance to see
characters from the animated series like
CJ hook Freddy facile ear and Zevon who
would you like to see in descendants 3
don't be shy to answer in the comment
section below
Lonnie's new challenge as soon as we saw
the sword fight we immediately noticed
someone who stood out from the others
everyone was surprised when this person
revealed that she was actually a girl
but then when we saw it was mulan's
daughter Lani we knew that it totally
made sense unfortunately she didn't have
the chance to join the swords and shield
team because she was a girl and it was
against the rules it didn't stop her
from saving Ben since that day Jay knew
that she would have the chance to sword
fight for the school team too and if she
can't be a member of the team she is
going to be the captain Mulan was
probably proud of her daughter who
finally defeated the odds without having
to hide the fact that she was a girl
Lani was one of our favorite characters
and this is why we want to see what is
going to happen to her in descendants 3
she was even Jays date for the cotillion
dance and we are wondering if she is
ever going to be his girlfriend but it
would be even more amazing to see a
young woman who doesn't need a man we
think that all the fans would be really
happy if Lani could get a little more
attention in the movie she totally
deserves it now and Harry Secret you
probably already know that dove Cameron
and Thomas Doherty who plays Harry hook
are dating in real life and if you don't
really care about celebrities you
absolutely noticed that there was a big
chemistry on set when the two were
filming a scene together it almost
ruined the scene because these two
characters were supposed to hate each
other and their connection was too
intense this is why Dov and Thomas
decided to come up with a little story
to explain all this Mao and Harry used
to date when they were on the Isle of
the Lost
she was the baddest of the bad and he
was the baddest of the bad so they made
the perfect couple
but then she broke his heart and Harry
decided to join Emma because they both
hated now that would explain why these
two still have some feelings for each
other it would be great to hear more
about this story in dissonance 3 after
all filmmakers need to explain to the
viewers why these two characters are
acting this way when they are together
let's just hope that bin won't be
jealous if you watch this video and tell
the end don't
get to write team descendants in the
comments and tell us what you would like
to see in the third movie we'd love to
hear what you think it's all going down
under the steam whether your team mom or
a team OMA under the sea has every
dissonance fan on the edge the trailers
definitely revealed some clues but watch
until the end to find out which is the
most shocking of them all Mouse
superpowers okay let's get one major
clue out of the way it's pretty clear
that under the sea will revolve around
you must avenge we can't blame her
really that what does seem incredibly
suspicious is the fact that mal is
clearly underwater did Disney forget
that she's not able to swim or is there
a deeper meaning to her suddenly
superpowers this small little detail
definitely changes everything we know
about descendants three if mal can
suddenly swim it definitely does mean
that it'll go down in the underworld and
we'll be in for an amazing battle under
the sea also makes it very clear that
both mal and uma will be alive after
their battles as they're both featured
in the original movie but it really does
look like now we'll be gaining some
pretty impressive superpowers let's take
it back to the first descendants movie
remember when mal and then took a dip
and now revealed she can't swim the
reason behind it was because there's a
barrier around the Isle of the Lost
that revenge swimming so this either
means that mal and Mo weren't even on
the owl of the Lost anymore or the
barrier has been removed or you know
maybe there's more to mal than we think
but more about that later
either way it's safe to say now has some
new superpowers how did she get them we
have a feeling that's where the third
movie will actually be about will Emma
turn good disney loves happy endings and
while this isn't strictly a clue from
under the sea itself it's definitely
something noticeable have you noticed
how all trailers mainly revolve around
now and she actually looks way more
powerful the new month maybe this will
all be an intervention for Emma and
she'll end up turning good we know some
parts of the movie will definitely
revolve around auradon so maybe we'll
see a different side of uma and an
unexpected happy ending we love our
pirate crew though so we're not entirely
sure how to feel about this but based on
the fact that mal looks stronger than
ever it's safe to say that uma might be
in a lot of trouble of coure
we won't really know what's going on
until the actual under-the-sea comes out
so make sure you come back for more
clues but it's safe to say under the sea
will continue to be Ouma Speights what
do you think will she turn good or with
that completely ruin her into her pirate
gangs bad image to be completely honest
we're not entirely sure if we want Harry
hook to get rid of his bad side either
but you can't deny that Disney loves at
tap en Davis
huge focus on now one thing we do know
is that based on under the sea Mao will
once again be the main focus of
descendents three surprise surprise of
course she's one of the main characters
so this should be totally expected but
it appears that some fans are getting
tired of seeing her storyline
highlighted more than others under the
sea cast doesn't even include the rest
of the main descendants characters which
gives a pretty good idea in the
direction of the actual movie we know
they'll be in the movie but based on
everything that's going on their parts
might be completely minor considering we
also have mouthed dad in the picture
this time dad it's safe to say mal is
into going anywhere unless her
underwater adventure with uma ends badly
so we don't really think that will
happen however there is one clue that we
definitely get from under the sea but
you'll have to watch until the end to
find out what it is are you tired of now
being the focus of all three movies and
stealing the spotlight from others we're
never getting the blonde hair back hate
to break it to you but that now seems to
be officially buried in the descendants
archives well based on under the sea she
has completely moved on from her old
school look the new mal is definitely
much darker and way more intense than
any other versions we've seen you can
also notice the change in her actual
fashion mouse clothes definitely evolves
from the very first descendants movie
her outfit usually featured a very
bright shade of green which gradually
faded more and more with each movie if
you look closely at her clothes during
the under-the-sea trailer it's pretty
clear that the Green is pretty much
non-existent we doubt they'll bring it
back for the movie so it's safe to say
we're getting a much darker mal but by
the looks of it her darker clothing and
hair definitely fit the theme of the
entire movie it's no longer sunshine and
rainbows this is now serious business
and while we thoroughly enjoyed the
blonde hair mouth we totally prefer her
darker and mature look the underworld by
now the entire descendent fandom knows
that descendants
will revolve in the underworld most
people have also managed to put two and
two together and find out that the
underworld is where Hades lives we don't
see much of Hades in under-the-sea
trailer but we still managed to get some
potential clues about his storyline but
more about that later the underworld
clue lies in the actual title while the
term under the sea means underneath the
actual surface it could also mean way
below the sea level after all that's
where Hades lives and judging by these
awesome behind-the-scenes photos that's
where we're really headed these belong
to just Jared jr. dot-com and they
really provide more insight into the
underworld and from what it seems like
we'll also get to meet Hades
three-headed dog it all just sounds like
the third movie will be incredibly eye
contact the question is will the battle
between maou and uma happen in Hades
underworld or just under the seed we
have a feeling that prequel to the movie
will leave us with a cliffhanger and we
won't find out the outcome of their
battle until the actual movie now that
would be the ultimate clickbait wouldn't
it music the music for under-the-sea
trailer looks totally intense of course
no soundtracks have been released yet
because it's way too early but have you
noticed just how much darker these sound
effects are we got pretty much freaked
out by mouths strange voice effects come
for you first
it's not yet clear whether under the sea
will even have any music to begin with
and by the looks of it it definitely
wouldn't fit the theme but what does
this mean for the actual movie will we
be getting much darker music we all know
the descendants franchise has some head
bopping music that's incredibly catchy
there are box there are choreographies
but would all of that fit into the stark
theme this music definitely exists for
the third movie as we've seen dub
Cameron mentioned she's been recording
it but judging by the under-the-sea
trailers it might look like the music
will be incredibly dark it's safe to say
we can say goodbye to bops like rotten
to the core and 9 is young fans have
been begging for another ballad like if
only but based on the theme up under the
sea the third movie might just be way
too dark for ballads unless it comes
from Hades which were totally here for
descendants marathon under the sea
trailers revealed brand new information
about the third movie he won't be able
to find them in the actual trailers by
now we know that
under the sea will come out on Friday
September 28th at 7:42 750 p.m. eastern
Pacific Standard Time it's going to be
some of the most anticipated 10 minutes
of our lives of what's even more
exciting is that under the sea is a part
of a dissonance marathon this means that
on the day Disney will be showing us
everything about descendents including
the movies of course you didn't think
this was the end of the story but will
also end up getting some
never-before-seen footage of dissonance
3 we have a feeling Disney will
definitely drop an official descendants
3 trailer we all know that the very
first trailer that came out was actually
meant for under the sea so they still
owe us at least one trailer the marathon
starts at 3:30 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time if you want to catch
never-before-seen footage you'll have to
watch the entire thing as it's not
exactly clear when we'll get more
information either way this is
incredibly exciting will you be watching
we definitely will is Mouse dad evil ok
we have a lot to talk about when it
comes to a tease first of all how cool
is this underworld the most importantly
on which side is he actually on
descendants can be very confusing
considering the main characters are
actually villains but what does that
make Hades is see one of the good guys
or is he actually more evil than any of
them combined did you notice that you
could actually see the blue orb from the
first trailer clearly behind the fake
dizzy and the gang perhaps this is a
hint that he's actually working on
Emma's side and not on mouth we still
don't know why mal was walking through
the forest but by the looks of it this
was Emma set up but since we can clearly
see the blue orb which mal even
recognises could that mean that Hades is
anonymous plan 2 we know there's a
reason he's not around but does this
mean mal could be in bigger trouble than
we think
under the sea will definitely foreshadow
how Mao even meets her dad in the first
place and we have a feeling he'll
definitely disappoint her way darker
than other movies we talk about the dark
theme a lot but we have to point out
that by the looks of it the third movie
will be way darker than any others
the sound effects indicate a pretty evil
theme and considering this is a prequel
it's safe to say the movie will follow
the same lead of course it still needs
to be child-friendly based on the
demographics of the franchise but it
just looks like things will definitely
take a dark turn we already have
there's four mouths transformed voice
come for you first it's only natural for
franchise movies to grow and develop so
it's safe to say no one really expected
the vibrant colors we saw from the first
one but we still hope Disney will be
able to put the perfect balance between
the dark theme and the slightly more
uplifting happy ending we all love so
much what do you think will they be able
to get it right or will this be a
completely different movie from the rest
we might need several more short movie
follow-ups after this just because so
much will be going on has now turned
evil one of the biggest potential clues
of this prequel is that Mao has actually
turned evil of course she was always
evil considering she's a villains kid
you know what we mean she's definitely
not as bad as Maleficent and she's had
her endearing moments that have made us
all fall in love with her but after
watching the under-the-sea trailers it's
safe to say that something is wrong with
the way she acts she can suddenly swim
her eyes are basically neon green and
her voice makes her sound like she's
actually possessed it's her dad involved
or is it all of his work since the
storyline will pretty much revolve
around mouth perhaps Disney will put
focus on trying to rescue her from
whatever situation she's in our guess is
she's being stuck in the underworld
after her battle with Ouma in under the
sea what do you think Disney is good at
keeping things under the rug but we
promise we're going to get to the bottom
of this once and for all what are your
theories about the third dissonance
movie are you team now or team Ouma
let's talk it out in the comments and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]